how are you bones damn good morning
salami homies good morning um wow that
is a great question Dan um well if I
said Tim Duncan in New York that'd be
good or Tim Duncan with a pulse either
way up to say Tim Duncan's career / /
Vince's career does Vince Vince was is
exciting those dunks are great but
Duncan's one of the greatest players of
all time yeah isn't there a kind of like
a moralistic tone to that question or
thought process about the winning part
of it and when you get down to it I mean
if you if you went back to the early
part of Tim's career and watched the way
that he played and you know you're
excited about the dunking aspect of of
the game you know TD would would put it
on some guys down low now was it Vince
Carter like no cuz Vince's maybe other
than dr. J and Michael the best dunker
the games ever seen and I'm probably the
best dunker the games ever seen and so
if that excites you have at it but Tim's
career has been has been remarkable did
guys try to get in Duncan's face during
games because Tim doesn't show any
emotion whatsoever well it didn't work
for the shorter guys but like Kevin
Garnett I was always told try to get in
Duncan's face yeah you know um Tim Tims
pretty much not lost about everything I
could there isn't really too much that
gets him gets him riled up either way
you know even if guys are are getting
after him he doesn't react and even if
he's getting after them he doesn't react
all that much it's just today that you
can't get into him it's just no way to
do that I I kind of thinking about this
question on the other side of the dam
with like if I asked you if you would
rather have the career of brent
mussberger or Howard Cosell where would
you go I
brent mussberger good call yeah i'm
going to send i'm going to send fritzy a
photo I've been out doing doing a
playoffs and it's kind of fun because a
lot of the people who are in production
for and the playoff games have been
around the business for a very long time
they're very very good at their job it's
pretty amazing some of the stories that
they have but Howie thinner who is a
producer for what we're doing during the
playoffs right now has worked for the
msg network for years and years and
years and he he found a picture of a
prick covering the 1976 NBA Finals with
brent mussberger and I'm gonna send that
photo to fritzy and you guys can have a
look at one of the most amazing leisure
suits you baby so this is your dad 1976
that was uh Celtics Phoenix eyes that it
fell tecton's great call and uh you know
which is weird because at the time my
dad was still playing so he would finish
and be eliminated from the playoffs the
Golden State and then get to do you know
the finals well the previous year they
won the title that is correct yeah but
we were we were talking about this and I
tell the dead ends about this it feels
like today's big man would rather
embarrass himself at the line than to
actually lower himself to try to do
underhand as your dad your dad did it
and shot over ninety percent from the
line if I took Drummond I mean all of
these big men hey Andre Jordan and I
just said let's try underhand do you
think they would do it if I said I can
improve you to sixty-five percent as
opposed to 50 or less than that would
they be willing to do that even though
how they would look shooting underhanded
what I know Shaq um jack tells me the
story about when Dale Brown was coaching
him at LSU that he brought my dad's LSU
and you don't had the idea to have him
go ahead and try to shoot the underhand
thing and he did for a day and the
fighting is jack tells the story he goes
man i started to shoot the underhand I
made a couple free throws but I was like
I'm not doing that all right hey okay so
you were better at it but you're not
going to do it in my crazy weird they
it's a weird thing I don't know what the
connection is too
not doing it I don't know if you know
you said you said it interestingly where
you said lower yourself to shooting
under and you know that's the way
everybody used to shoot that's the way
everybody used to shoot from the
perimeter when the game first started
lot of guys from the outside would stop
to go back to old tapes stop jump stop
two hands you know get the ball at the
waist and throw the ball towards the
basket and so yeah it's very peculiar
that some guys or that nobody will adopt
it I think there's one there's one
college player at Louisville dip that
shot it this year underhand did this
season did you did it interesting we're
talking to brent Barry NBA TV analyst
he's got tonight's game between the
Thunder and the Mavericks by the way
getting a little chippy there with these
two teams with with Durant and Russell
Westbrook and Dirk get knocked down and
what do you make of what will happen
tonight here well I think the Dallas his
of you know as much as Rick Carlisle who
was brilliant after game 3 I don't know
if you watch dating the press conference
room Rick Carlisle was asked a question
by one of the Oklahoma City beat writers
who had said something along the lines
of Rick have you seen a change in the
Oklahoma City team's demeanor especially
Serge Ibaka and Enes Kanter making it
dirty down there for your guys and Rick
Carlisle responded by I'm sorry what's
your name and the reporter said his name
and then Rick said and you said that
those two guys cancer and Ibaka played
dirty and the guy said yeah that's what
I asked he goes okay I just want to make
sure rectly oh so I I think that what
Dallas has to do is make the game
physical in that way and I know Rick
Carlisle sort of put it on ok Oklahoma
City but with all of the decimation with
the guard play and injuries that they
have right now Dirk's knee even
bothering him before going into Game
three now maybe misery out because he
had a little hip thing up in the fourth
quarter for them they're just running
out of bodies and so the more and more
that
can kind of slow it up and be physical
to try to get Oklahoma City off of their
game the better but they're just out man
there's just no way that they can slow
down Westbrook and Durant who actually
in the series Dan have not played great
it's really been cancer and Ibaka and
Mauro are at Cantor vodka and waiters
who've been remarkable in the series
which is a good sign for Oklahoma City
with all things considered possibly
tonight moving on to play San Antonio to
have those guys be in a confident mode
Lakers fire Byron Scott is this Luke
Waltons job I mean I just don't see how
Luke is not the guy for them and and how
hard they go after Luke to go back to
Southern California and coachup the
Lakers I just that they would love to
have it's gonna be an interesting
decision for Luke wall but don't you
think they fire Byron Scott because they
know that Luke Walton wants to do it
like they they agree in principle does
that it's that far-fetched I don't know
what the Lakers over the past five years
could you see that maybe they're not
sure well they could screw it up in the
front office absolutely absolutely yeah
I yeah I don't know I that's an
interesting question I'll be I have
really no no inside information with
regards to that I wish I did to tell you
but I that job would be so attractive to
Luke and so difficult to turn down given
who it is it's there where they are
where they need to go and the type of
communicator that that Luke is the way
that he would connect to that young core
down there I think would be would be
fantastic before I let you go i
mentioned that steph curry getting hurt
wanting to come back couldn't play in
the second half but usually an athlete
knows when something's different you
know with their body that that you know
that do you think Steph Curry knows the
severity of that knee injury right now
before the MRI results I I don't think
so really yeah I don't think it's that
that injury and maybe you guys um you
guys have there's obviously enough
athletes in the room with you right now
you guys maybe have had that little Nina
on the inside your knee maybe you're
playing with your buddies where you bump
that me and you're not exactly sure
what's going on in there but definitely
given that the game before he was hurt
and that that this one was restricting
him in some way I mean there's there's
two ways that can go there's there's two
cl's down there there's an admin an a
and if one is one way there's no way
he's coming back and if one's another it
could be a rest situation on the ACL
side of things where it would be a
couple weeks and could Golden State
survive a couple weeks that would be
real interesting i just can't believe in
keep scratching in my head that with the
NBA playoffs starting and all the things
that the second round was going to offer
up and will offer up with regards to the
teams that are involved in the Western
Conference that Steph Curry is the guy
that's hurt I mean it's just it really
has taken a little bit of wind out of
the sails for me good catch up with your
bones have fun tonight with the thunder
and mouths such eight Eastern on TNT a
doubleheader tonight followed by the
Clippers in the Blazers thanks Dan hi
buddy guys are well night brent Barry
former slam dunk champ the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience